[Aplausos]
cuando ustedes eran niños que querían
ser cuando fueran grandes
bailarina cantante uno más
actor bueno cuando yo tenía seis años
iba en segundo de primaria y sobre lo
que todos queríamos ser cuando fuéramos
grandes por supuesto que todos mis
compañeritos tenían sumamente decidido
que querían ser cuando fueran grandes
cantantes bailarines futbolistas
profesionales científicos locos ya saben
todo lo que un niño piensa que jamás
sería ni aburrido y cotidiano por
supuesto que yo también tenía sumamente
decidido qué es lo que quería hacer
cuando fuera grande así que llegó el día
de preparar mi exposición domingo a las
10 de la noche no había comprado la
cartulina por cierto y se sienta en mis
planes frente a mí y me preguntan oye
karen a todo esto lo que quiere ser
cuando seas grande y con la firmeza que
yo sentía por ese sueño con la
convicción de verdaderamente verme
logrando lo les dije quiero ser la mejor
maestra de aerobics que puede existir
sabéis en los coros no había crecido
algo mucho más cool en esa época era lo
que conocía entonces me encantaba y
tenía mis rutinas y tenía hasta una
barbilla aeróbica
yo estaba totalmente convencida de que
lo iba a lograr pero esa niña de firme
convicción empieza a formar un estándar
de lo que para el mundo representa ser
una persona exitosa
empieza a darse cuenta de lo que
necesitas y lo que requieres cumplir
para cumplir con este estándar y
entonces todo el tiempo que te consume
que te envuelve a través de la
televisión a través de la escuela a
través del mundo paralelo del internet
donde ya todo es perfecto y entonces las
ganas de salir adelante ya no eran
dictadas por la inspiración de hacer
algo que me gustara empezaron a ser
dictadas por un miedo tremendo al
fracaso
tenía un pánico espantoso de ser una
persona invisible ya que ya karen de 6
años que había decidido ser la mejor
maestra de aerobics se dio cuenta de que
esa idea
definitivamente no encajaba con la idea
que tiene el mundo de ser una persona
exitosa así que llegamos al momento en
el que cumplo 17 años y me doy cuenta de
que me encanta una de las profesiones
que estoy segura que la mayoría de los
que están aquí preferiría mil veces una
clase de aerobics antes que una clase de
derecho decidido a estudiar derecho y
asumir todo lo que ese rol representaba
y aunque muy en el fondo había decidido
estudiar esta carrera porque siempre
creí que a través del derecho podría
tener la oportunidad de incidir por
tener un mundo con
y con más justicia la verdad es que eso
es algo que yo jamás dije en voz alta
porque decir eso era lo más ilusorio o
simplemente sonaba como a frase que
cualquier político trillado diría así
que recuerdo los primeros semestres de
la facultad donde todos llegamos muy
vestiditos ya nos creemos magistrados y
vamos con un portafolio a todas las
clases que lo único que trae es un
sandwich
yo recuerdo mucho que no teníamos pero
ni la menor idea de lo que representa
verdaderamente enfrentarte al mundo real
y me sumí a leyendo historias de lideres
poderosísimos que a través de la
historia que a través de las palabras
lograron modificar su entorno era gente
que con una sola palabra lograba
incentivar a la lucha al cambio a la
revolución y siempre lo veía y decía
así quiero ser y específicamente
recuerdo en una clase a las 7 de la
mañana a la hora en que sólo podemos
pensar que tanto vale la pena vivir
estábamos hablando sobre el premio nobel
de la paz más joven de la historia mala
la isaps hay una activista internacional
ya los 15 años recibió un disparo en la
cabeza por materializar a través de las
palabras la terrible realidad de su
comunidad una activista que decidió
defender los derechos de las niñas y las
mujeres por tener acceso a la educación
málaga tiene 22 años y hoy ha hablado en
frente de los líderes más poderosos de
todo el mundo en la organización de las
naciones unidas en cada palabra que dice
en cada tweet que manda mi yo
de personas alrededor del mundo
encuentran una inspiración poderosísima
así que yo recuerdo que salí de esa
clase totalmente ensimismada y pensaba y
tú que hace chocar
tienes 20 años y no tienes ni la
fortaleza de decir porque estudiaste
realmente derecho bueno es más no tienes
ni cinco seguidores en 'twitter'
y yo recuerdo que me consumía tanto la
idea porque además lo comparaba era
inevitable y decía mala la tenía que
enfrentar circunstancias extraordinarias
y yo estoy en un país donde alzar la voz
no implica un acto heroico donde decir
lo que empieza lo que piensas realmente
no implica arriesgar tu vida y tal vez
comparado con malala el peor fracaso las
peores circunstancias que yo podría
enfrentar era tener que alcanzar el
camión corriendo porque estaba lloviendo
y porque a mí no me tocó el potro bus
entonces me sentía totalmente pasmado
por un fracaso a la vida era una persona
invisible y además de una persona
fracasada cuando ni siquiera había
intentado algo yo se los cuento así
sonriendo y de una buena manera pero eso
fue el pensamiento más triste que alguna
persona podría tener sobre sí misma
así que en esta irrupción
pensé cómo voy a ser exitosa si no he
hecho nada tengo que dar el primer paso
el primer paso es actuar que tienes que
hacer no sé por qué no tenía una ruta me
queda claro pero empecé a actuar así que
un día saliendo de clases de la facultad
de derecho salí súper emocionada llegué
a mi casa me comienzan los de mi
portafolio abrí mi computadora y empecé
a redactar un correo al entonces
secretario de las naciones unidas ban
ki-moon querido señor ban ki-moon por
medio de la presente porque ya me habían
dado clases para redactar oficios me
permite expresar mi sueño por ser la
mejor joven que va a luchar por los
derechos humanos quiero ir al foro más
importante de derechos humanos porque yo
estoy dispuesta a cambiar el mundo y lo
voy a lograr leí y releí la carta le
cambié le puse negrita le puse menos
todo lo que implica hacer una carta y
después de casi cuatro horas la envié me
atreví a enviarla había dado el primer
paso sería la computadora y entonces en
frente de los dos días más ansiosos que
he tenido cuando estamos esperando un
resultado y solo estás pensando en ello
hizo en algo y volteas y solamente son 1
y entonces yo estaba esperando todo el
tiempo esta noticia hasta que escucha la
notificación del correo me siento en
frente de mi computadora y con las
palpitaciones al mí por ahora temblando
abro mi correo y ahí estaba
bienvenida al club sitio porque vamos a
como se me ocurrió pensar que el
secretario general de las naciones
unidas iba a responderme mi correo por
supuesto que no el éxito no se hace de
un día para otro o sea la intención no
basta y mi generación o nuestra
generación estamos acostumbrados a
querer todo fácil y rápido y no es así
recuerdo que es inspiración brutal que
yo tenía por cambiar las cosas por hacer
la diferencia me duró aproximadamente
como tres meses bueno menos como cinco y
entonces en este periodo de inspiración
llegué a la facultad dirige puede ser un
grupo cultural no hay entonces todo lo
que eso implicaba porque según yo iba a
ser un semillero de los próximos líderes
de opinión de todo el país y el grupo
del pasillo de mi facultad imagínese un
pasillo enorme larguísimo con ventanales
transparentes me paré en la puerta desde
las nueve de la mañana y empecé para que
tal buenos días mucho gusto mi nombre
karen garcía rivas galindo nos
interesaría un ir de este grupo hola que
tal buenos días se los juro dije mi
nombre casi como 300 veces y vaya que
tiene cuatro apellidos
y de esas 300 veces que dije mi nombre
solamente 50 personas 50 me dijeron ok
pero es lo que para mí era lo máximo
iudice así jota pero no los digo cabe
destacar que dentro de esos 50 pues como
siete o diez eran mis amigos y sé que
por eso me dijeron que sí pero bueno con
eso me bastaba así que empecé a
estructurar todo un plan de trabajo y
genere el proyecto para hacer es la gran
asamblea de este grupo cultural móvil
cielo mar y tierra para que me prestara
en el auditorio de la facultad me gasté
la beca escolar haciendo las carpetas de
trabajo para todos los integrantes me
lleve todo el café y el azúcar de mi
casa no es cierto y entonces llegó al
auditorio me paré enfrente de la puerta
esperando a mis 50 integrantes del grupo
cultural y así estuve parada más de tres
horas de los 50 que yo esperaba llegaron
ocho personas y las ocho personas que
llegaron eran mis amigos
y de nueva cuenta sabía que estaban ahí
porque me querían pero ya lo
había intentado o sea ya había actuado
que estaba saliendo mal y no crean no
creo que eso me basto o sea yo no sé qué
chip me picó que entre más fracasaba más
más quería hacer las cosas y después la
mente cafés literarios quién es un café
literario alce la mano o por qué no
fueron amigos solamente cambios
literarios días culturales mañanas
deportivas todo lo que se les ocurra
competencias de debate de oratoria lo
que permitiera alzar la voz lo que
permitiera que ya no fuera más una
persona invisible
después de eso después de pintar y
fracasar como una verdadera maestra el
dolor era terriblemente peor porque
ahora sí ya lo había intentado porque
ahora sí ya me había movilizado y no
tenía resultado alguno y ni siquiera era
un por acaso así por acaso nivel donde
es el empresario que generó algo
increíble y de un día para otro le
hicieron un fraude o alguien que
invirtió dinero y lo perdió renuncia una
beca de harvard porque se fue al espacio
yo que sé de esas historias que vemos
todos los días que las escuchas y te
inspiras están mis fracasos no servían
ni para inspirar a nadie
yo decía bueno que está pasando que
estoy haciendo y lo que no me había dado
cuenta es que después de ello logré
derrotarme en mí misma y logré renunciar
a la idea que el mundo tiene sobre el
éxito por primera vez empecé a trabajar
en mí y me hice esta pregunta como
pretendo que el mundo me vea como una
persona exitosa si yo no me siento así
como pretendo que el mundo me deje de
ver como alguien invisible si yo no me
puedo ni ver al frente del espejo
después de esta gran experiencia
personal y el primer paso y obtuve el
primer éxito de los más poderosos que
hoy he tenido después de seis meses de
mucho esfuerzo bajé 20 kilos y no hubo
un éxito que representara lo mejor por
la parte física sino porque por primera
vez había renunciado al estándar de lo
que el mundo te exige que seas por
primera vez me sentí la mejor maestra de
aerobics en el mundo
después de ese éxito después de ese paso
dado y de haber fracasado como una
verdadera maestra de verdad voy a dar un
curso de coaching por si usted para
fracasa
siguió trabajando y entonces lo seguí
intentando y ahora seguía alzando la voz
seguía siendo las mismas ideas que yo
tenía pero el fracaso empezó a saber me
distinto empezó a generar esas pequeñas
gotas de miel en el frasco de mis éxitos
y por cada diez personas que había de
las 100 que faltaban yo me sentía
sumamente poderosa porque ahora sí
éramos diez personas alzando la voz y
estas diez personas bastaban para
empezar a hacer la diferencia entre unos
y otros
la magia ocurrió después después de
intentar y de intentar y de darme cuenta
de que la fuerza de mis palabras y la
fuerza de mis acciones es igual de
valiosa que la fuerza que siente mal a
la cuando hablo en frente de miles de
líderes mundiales cuando acepte eso me
sentí sumamente poderosa y después de
mucho y después de tanto logré con
aquellos amigos que siempre estuvieron a
mi lado generaron una plataforma de
participación universitaria donde más de
500 alumnos después de seis años siguen
alzando la voz y siguen haciendo
propuestas para nuestro país el
simulador legislativo de la universidad
logré ser campeona de debate a nivel
estatal y representar al estado de
méxico a nivel nacional diciendo lo que
verdaderamente pensaba logra dar
discursos poderosísimos en frente de
gente que no tenía la menor idea de
quién era
logré irme de movilidad a otro país y
alzar la voz en nombre de méxico alzar
el teléfono y hablarles a mis papás
llorando de la emoción que sentía
y logré de verdad sentirme la persona
más exitosa y no porque lo fuera porque
me queda claro y no tengo la menor duda
de que aquí hay gente que ha hecho cosas
mucho más extraordinarias y mucho más
maravillosas y de verdad lo admiro y de
verdad lo aprecio pero yo llevaba más de
22 años reconociendo los éxitos de todas
las personas que me rodeaban jamás me
había dado la oportunidad y jamás me
había dado el regalo de reconocer lo que
para mí representaba haber logrado tanto
estos pequeños éxitos y fracasos
cotidianos me habían forjado de una
manera particular ahora ya no tenía
miedo al fracaso ahora era mi amigo y
era parte de lo que yo hacía todos los
días y no quiere decir que esta charla
implique que yo ya soy una persona
realizada y sumamente exitosa nombre
ojala el fracaso sigue siendo el mejor
amigo pero ya me calle no yo nos
llevamos muy bien hace dos meses por
ejemplo renuncié al ley al trabajo de
mis sueños un trabajo que me costó
muchísimo trabajo estar ahí y me dolió
mucho y fue una circunstancia que de
verdad me tiró pero después de haber
renunciado después de sentirme triste y
derrotada dos días pasaron y vi en mi
facebook la convocatoria de este texto
que esa caída tan brutal me dio la
fuerza y me dio la inspiración para
estar aquí frente a ustedes porque me
queda claro que en el momento en que
cada uno revalore el y sé lo que
representa para ellos el éxito las cosas
se van a hacer hoy les pido que abracen
las mieles de su fracaso hoy les pido
que acepten los éxitos cotidianos todo
es un proceso y todo es un camino
pero no sirve de nada si no se aferran a
ello aferrarse a la miel y sus fracasos
a perderse a los éxitos cotidianos
aférrense a las ganas que todos tenemos
de ser la mejor maestra de aerobics en
el mundo muchas gracias
[Aplausos]